so drones and lasers you know you've got
a whole big lab now working on this when
will Facebook drones and lasers be ready
for launch well we're going to be
testing some in the in the near future
so I think that that's I'd be probably
mistaken if I gave you an exact date on
this but it's um that's one of the big
technical barriers right there are a lot
of people who don't live within range of
a network and drones and satellites and
laser communication is one way to do it
microwave communication is another is
are going to be some of the solutions
for providing more cost effective
connectivity to people where there are
no existing you know cell phone towers
or infrastructure like that you know
Facebook you made it clear on the
earnings call that Facebook is going to
be ramping up spending how much of that
is going to enter internet org and these
these efforts and you know the NASA
propulsion lab and and where you're
working on all this other cool
technology we're definitely investing a
bunch of this